little fun we're going to have now our
favorite all-time nfl press conferences
miles i'll give you the honors
okay well this one comes from derek
anderson who was a quarterback that i
watched growing up with the browns he
was really one of the only quarterbacks
who had a good season with the browns
when i was young in 2007 but when he
went to the arizona cardinals he played
on the monday night football game and
the cameras caught him laughing on the
sideline and after the game he had a
very interesting reaction to being
questioned about it you think this is
funny i think you're serious i'm not i'm
real serious i put my heart and soul
into this every single week all i'm
saying is the camera show i'm just
telling you right now what i do every
single week
every single week i put my freaking
heart and soul into this i study my ass
off i don't go out there and laugh it's
not funny it's not fun nothing's funny
to me i don't want to go out there and
get embarrassed on monday night football
in front of everybody
that was good that was very good and i
remember that i remember the night that
happened guy's intense i've had to mute
him on twitter he came at me a couple
times and the best approach in
situations like that is that that mute
that mute button is powerful because
they don't know they don't know that you
don't see what they're saying they can
say whatever they want it is the it is
the social media la la la not listening
i love it all right um this one
is extremely obscure
it has never been appreciated the way
that it should i take you back to the
late 80s possibly the early 90s there
was a guy named jerry burns who was the
head coach of the minnesota vikings he's
still alive i think we used to call him
bedhead burnsie among our unofficial
group of vikings fans because he always
looked like he had rolled right out of
bed here he is cursing like a sailor
roll of footage
i don't like to name names after a
[ __ ] after a [ __ ] game but we we
can't
we can't be responsible for the blocking
we can't be responsible for the guys
jumping offside we can't be responsible
for we get down there and and uh it was
a dumb play by by anderson i love i love
anderson
but it was a dumb [ __ ] play when he
had when his foot was
shoe was coming off up the line
screaming we were hard to take time out
we had a [ __ ] trap play called and
his [ __ ] shoe comes off
that's just part of it go to youtube go
to youtube
type in jerry burns jerry with a j just
like seinfeld and you will get to enjoy
the full thing and you there's a rabbit
hole out there of some coach
interactions with reporters that haven't
been widely appreciated jim moore has
been involved in a couple shockingly
he's got a couple of the all-time great
press conferences that we omitted
because we've seen them we've
appreciated them but miles jerry burns
just just beautiful beautiful stuff and
i had no idea he had that side to him
because nobody really paid attention it
was pre-internet it was you know you
didn't know he was that fiery very fiery
if you watch that whole video
imagine if a head coach started doing
that today man right after a game boy
that would be awesome because the thing
gets streamed everywhere all these teams
just stream their press conferences i
don't know what they would do it hit the
live view oh my god cut them off cut
them off be fantastic
yeah and uh that's right it's not like
you can you can do the live seven second
delay that never works i don't care how
good you are especially when he's going
machine gun f-bomb you just keep your
finger on that button until he stops
talking the whole thing's bleeped
it's worse than sims for crying out loud
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports